go to infinity dummies impossible
Colleen aah
Toy Story fans the new trailer for Toy
Story 4 just dropped and it looks epic
Bo Peep is back and she's changed a lot
keep watching to find out the truth
about Bo peeps return the trailer Disney
and Pixar happened keeping Toy Story 4
under wraps they've released a couple of
teaser trailers one showed some new toys
at a carnival to infinity and your mom
the other introduced porky the spork
that Bonnie turns into a toy we knew
that Bo Peep was returning in this movie
but we didn't know how but now we do on
march 19th 2019 Pixar dropped the first
full-length trailer of Toy Story 4 it is
going to be amazing
we are so excited to see all of our
favorite toys back together in the
trailer
woody introduced four key to the rest of
the toys woody understands at four Kia's
currently Bonnie's favorite toy it's up
to the rest of them to keep four keys
safe for their kid Bonnie and her family
go on a road trip in an RV for key
freaks out about his identity and jumps
out of the vehicle woody goes after him
he tries to make porky feel better but
then woody and porky walk by an antique
store
woody sees Bo Peep and goes in to find
her they are attacked by some creepy
antique toys who want them to stay but
Bo Peep rescues them she takes them to a
carnival woody says he has to get back
to Bonnie and Bo teases him about always
doing the right thing she tells him that
there are plenty of toys and plenty of
kids she says change can be a good thing
buzz and the rest of the toys go after
woody and Corky Bonnie is devastated
that her toys are missing and woody has
to make a decision between bean free are
returning to his kid we are totally
digging this plot what will woody decide
Bo peeps return has left us with some
serious questions why doesn't she want
to go back why doesn't she want to be a
toy anymore bo sure is acting a lot like
other villain toys has Little Bo Peep
turned into Big Bad peep neglected toys
let's look at the facts from the
previous movies in the world of Toy
Story toys are created to bring joy to
children that is their purpose in life
for key is dealing
this identity issue because he never
meant to be a toy but what happens to
toys that are neglected or abused by
kids in the previous films they turn
evil in the first Toy Story did treats
his toys terribly and they become total
monsters and the worst villain of all
was in Toy Story 3 Lotso had been lost
by his child and replaced he turned into
a vicious toy dictator he was actually
pretty scary for a purple teddy bear and
then the antique toys and the new
trailer are creepy and evil they haven't
been played with in a long time
according to the Toy Story universe it's
really bad when toys are abused or
neglected to stay good and kind they
have to have a kid it sure looks like Bo
Peep has not lived with a kid for a long
time what do you say I get someone else
to watch the Sheep tonight what happened
- Bo Bo Peep was Woody's girlfriend from
the first and second movies she was a
toy of mrs. Davis that sat on a shelf
but she joins up with Andy's toys bo was
missing from the third movie woody says
that they have lost friends along the
way including Bo woody says that some
have been donated or sold and some have
been broken and thrown out we are never
told what actually happened to Bo well
she definitely wasn't broken
she could have been donated or sold by
mrs. Davis she could have also been
thrown out either way both somehow ends
up far from home she was an antique and
woody sees her in an antique store it's
likely that she was sold she ends up at
the faraway antique store but she isn't
happy at all she misses her friends she
wants to be a toy and Bo was a strong
independent toy she would not put up
with the other creepy antique toys she
finds her way out of the store outside
she discovers the carnival and freedom
she doesn't know where she is
or how to get home so she goes rogue and
becomes a free toy Bo the villain we
don't know exactly when Bo went missing
but it's definitely veneers a lot has
happened and Bo has definitely seen some
stuff in a trailer bo makes fun of woody
for wanting to get back to Bonnie she
teases him for doing the right thing
since when is doing the right thing bad
come on Bo then she shows woody the
carnival she introduces him to what life
is like as a free toy when he tells her
that he was meant to help kids she
dismisses him
cool bow she is trying to lure him to
the dark side but we know what happens
to toys without kids would he still
loves her and she uses that against him
she shows in how much fun life can be
and it sure looks like she's going to
make him choose between her and Bonnie
that's not a healthy relationship at all
the trailer makes us think that beau is
definitely the villain in the new movie
why else would she talk about kids like
that poor woody he thought he would
never see her again and he was right
because this isn't the bow he knew and
loved she's changed we hope would he
makes the right decision and we really
hope that Beau's love for woody will
make her turn good again maybe seeing
the other toys will make her have a
change of heart
Bonnie would totally love beau but we
know from Toy Story 3 that not every toy
can have a happy ending bouck convinced
many of the toys to go free maybe she
even convinces forky to stay with her he
never wanted to be a toy in the first
place we can't wait to see what happens
Toy Story 4 will be in theaters on June
21st 2019 what do you think will happen
to Beau and woody don't be shy tell us
your theories in the comment section
thanks for watching give this video a
big thumbs up if you're excited to watch
Toy Story 4 new around here don't forget
to hit that subscribe button for the
latest Disney news we'll catch you next
time
[Music]